we call them for good reason adult
relationships
that is relationships entered into when
we are grown up and committed to the
principles and virtues of a mature
existence
what can be paradoxical therefore is the
extent to which in the finest couples
the atmosphere owes a debt to certain of
the moods and interests of early
childhood
for a start we might want to call the
partner baby
and they might call us poppet
we might speak in slightly younger
voices and in a higher register
we might buy them a furry giraffe and
they might buy us an equally adorable
soft toy version of a golden retriever
the two animals might even play games
with one another and give each other
cuddles when they are sad
it can all look in the bright light of
day highly unfortunate and regressive
but this would be to overlook how much
adult love necessarily sits on a base
created in childhood
and therefore should when it is going
well
share certain characteristics with the
better moments of our pasts
it is no sign of folly when we use
diminutives with our loved ones
it is evidence that we have found our
way back to the vulnerability
defenselessness and need that we once
knew how to express and entertain with
refreshing guilelessness
and that we must reconnect with in order
to have a chance to love
even if we are in the rest of our lives
mature defense attorneys
senior cardiac nurses or lauded venture
capitalists
we might in turn
wonder at those who appear too keen to
dismiss sentimental child-based play as
babyish we might ask what happened to
the infantile part of them and why it
had to be disowned so forcefully
we might explore how hard it is for them
to be witnessed as fragile
and therefore perhaps to be gentle
around the fragility of others
true maturity doesn't ultimately
mean quashing all evidence of weakness
or immaturity it means according the
younger part of us it's due within the
totality of our capacities
it calls for an ability to mother or
father the younger self of the partner
and to allow them to do likewise to us
we may have to wait until we are real
adults
before we can re-learn how to play
and love with some of the authenticity
and uncensored frankness of our
three-year-old selves
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more